Stereo is not the only technique that a robot
can use to determine the 3D structure of its
world. This is a very familiar device; it's
the Microsoft Connect Sensor. This is sometimes
called an RGBD camera that is it's a sensor
that returns you at each pixel, the red value,
the green value, the blue value and the depth.
So, we talked earlier about color planes in
an image. The Connect Sensor returns an image
with 4 planes, R, G, B and D. The Connect
contains 2 quite separate subsystems.
The first is a fairly conventional color or
RGB camera. The second component is a laser
pattern projector. So, this is actually omitting,
a pattern of infrared light onto the scene
and then, there is an infrared camera which
is observing that pattern and from the observation
of the pattern, it can determine 3-dimensional
structure.
What does this pattern looks like? It's looks
pretty speckly, It’s pretty close to a random
pattern of dots.
What the Connect Sensor does is exploit a
very classical principle called structured
light. What I want to do here is to illustrate
the principles of a classical structured light
sensor.
The gray box here represents the Connect Sensor
and we have an object at some distance away
from the sensor. We have a camera which is
represented here by a pin hole camera model
with an image plane behind it and we have
a laser projector which emits a fan of rays.
Those rays intersect the object and forms
spots of light on the object. The camera observes
those spots of light and forms an image which
is a projection of those spots on the object.
Let's just make a temporary copy of where
those spots are on the image plane. Now, we're
going to consider that the object has moved
further away from the camera and we repeat
the process. The laser projector emits the
same fan of laser beams. Spots are formed
on the object. Pinhole camera observes that
and we see a projection on the image plane.
If we add back the previous image plane projection
which we say before, we can see that the pattern
of dots has moved. There is a vertical displacement
or a disparity that is proportional to the
object distance.
So, this is the fundamental principle of structured
light. Now, we can add some additional measurements
here. We have a base line which is the distance
between the center of laser projector and
the center of the camera.
The camera's got a focal length and the object
is at a distance z. Now, we can write a relationship
between all of these quantities and the disparity
is inversely proportional to the object distance
z.
So, this is not exactly how the Connect works
but it's a very similar principle. On the
Connect Sensor itself, the base line then
is the distance between the center of the
laser pattern projector and the center of
the infrared camera. Another principle is
what's called the time of flight camera and
what we can see here is a camera lens in the
middle and on the either side of that, there
are 2 arrays of quite high power light-emitting
diodes. These diodes don't project a speckle
pattern onto the scene. They provide general
overall illumination of the scene.
The principle works something like this. The
light that's being emitted is modulated at
some quite high frequency and is reflected
off the object and picked up by the camera.
So, the modulation frequency of light might
be something like 10 or 20 megahertz. If we
plot the intensity of a light against time,
the outgoing light in red and incoming light
in blue, we see that the incoming light is
slightly delayed with respect to the outgoing
light.
There is a phase shift. So, there's a delay
of T. The distance is proportional to the
phase difference between the outgoing and
the incoming light. The relationship between
distance and the time delay T is given here
where C is the speed of light. Speed of light
is a very big number that means that the time
shift is very small.
Typically, it's of the order of nano seconds.
This process is replicated at every single
pixel in the scene. So, we need a very special
sort of imaging sensor. One that's not just
responsive to the intensity of the incoming
light but a pixel that is responsive to phase
shift.
So, these cameras require very special sensing
chips and typically, don't have particularly
high resolution, maybe 64 by 64 pixels or
128 by 128. A generic disadvantage of this
kind of sensor and also the Connect Sensor
is that they rely on projecting light onto
the scene. This means that they don't work
particularly well outdoors where you've got
a very bright sun completely overwhelms the
light that the sensor is trying to project
onto the scene.
They do, however, work very very well indoors
and they work very very well at night where
a traditional camera will return nothing.